Starbucks got exposed for using child
labor at Starbucks you need billions of
coffee beans per year to keep your
Empire running so you go to the poorest
countries and tell the citizens that
you're going to solve all their problems
that you're going to provide housing
food clean drinking water everything
they need and all they have to do to pay
you back is work it off it sounds like
feudalism but trust me it's not and boom
just like that you have free laborers
who you can force to do anything you
want you can have them work for 18 hours
a day pay them as little as you please
and force them to do back-breaking labor
in harsh conditions that nobody else
would want to do you can even have their
kids work for you the great thing about
getting kids to work is that they're
more adaptable and less likely to rise
up against nasty working conditions
after all what's a little kid going to
do to fight against a giant company like
Starbucks or Nestle nothing